Good evening.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been a happy day.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Dasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Dasa
Namo tassa bhagavato anahato sambha sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
No doubt you've noticed the changing decor there.
The gold curtain, that is gold I think, yes.
When the sun shines through it, it is quite remarkable.
So we're moving on to the great sixfold base, the discourse on the great sixfold base.
So this is just an opportunity to revise everything.
Just like in any system, everything is interconnected and related to everything else.
So whenever you start in the Buddha's teachings, you eventually can include everything.
because it links from one to the next.
And this is what this discourse does for us.
So it's also a bit of a revision, going through all these different lists.
So we'll see what he says.
So on one occasion, the Blessed One was living at Sabotee again.
That's one of his favourite places up in the North Park there, at Anathapindika's Park.
And he says to the people listening,
i shall teach you a discourse on the great sixfold base listen and attend closely to what i say yes venables when one does not know and see the eye as it actually is one does not know and see forms as they actually are when one does not know and see eye consciousness as it actually is when one does not know and see as it actually is the feeling felt as pleasant
unpleasant or neutral, pleasant or neutral that arises with eye contact as a condition, then one is inflamed by indulgence for the eye, for forms, for eye consciousness, for eye contact, for feelings felt as pleasant, unpleasant and neutral that arise with eye contact as condition.
So these are your middle links, aren't they, of dependent origination, right?
The active part begins at the point of contact.
So the contact, remember, has to have these three ingredients.
It has to have a base, a sense base.
And remember, the mind is a sense base too.
The mind heart is a sense base too for emotions and thoughts, our inner life.
But for the outer life out there, what is that sense base of the eye, the retina, the object that we're looking at, and there has to be this consciousness.
If any of those are missing, then you basically don't see.
And it's dependent on that, that we experience whether something is pleasant or neutral.
So the first information that comes in doesn't have
That definition is just information, you might say.
It's just a colour or shape.
It's the next part which is connected with perception of concept, right?
So that when you look at a tree, the first impressions, remember, are just the colour and the shape of the tree.
That's all that the space gives you.
Then as it brought into the mind, it's given a certain...
feeling tone, pleasantness, happiness, and a certain understanding, tree.
And then, of course, there's that reaction of wanting it, wanting more tree, wanting to hug a tree, for heaven's sake.
Now, when one abides inflamed by overindulgence, compulsive indulgence, fettered, infatuated, contemplating gratification,
then the five aggregates affected by clinging are built up for oneself and in the future.
So these five aggregates, remember, the body, feeling, perceptions, concepts, all our habits, everything that we create through an act of will and consciousness.
And they are conditioned and conditioning.
So remember that.
It's important to grasp.
Every time you condition yourself in something,
It also has the effect of conditioning the future, which basically means the more biscuits you have, the more biscuits you want.
And this brings about the renewal of the desire to become like this.
This is the selfing process that carries on from it.
and is accompanied by delight and this indulgence and delights in this and that increases.
Now one's bodily mental troubles increase, one's physical and mental torments increase, one's physical and mental fevers increase, and one experiences physical and mental suffering, okay?
So all indulgence is bad for us, one way or the other, and it's really recognizing that, that makes us change our behavior.
So he's been through the eye contact, so now, of course, he goes through the rest of the five senses and the sixth sense, which is the mind.
Now, the opposite is true, of course, and you end up with once bodily and mental troubles are abandoned,
one's bodily and mental torments are abandoned, one's physical and mental fevers are abandoned, and one experiences physical and mental pleasure.
Now, you've got to be careful here.
Of course, indulgence in pleasant things also gives you physical and mental pleasure, but eventually they lead you to suffering.
This, when we don't indulge in something and we just enjoy it, then it doesn't lead to this further suffering.
To kiss a joy as it flies, to live in eternity's sunrise.
So now he tells us about the view.
So it comes from a person's understanding.
If we don't understand something properly or clearly, then of course we make these mistakes.
Now the view of a person such as this is right view.
His intention is right view.
His effort is right view.
His mindfulness is right mindfulness.
Sorry, I'll do that again.
His intention is right intention.
His effort is right effort.
His mindfulness is right mindfulness.
His concentration, right concentration.
In other words, here we have the Eightfold Path.
So it's right view, right intention, number one and number two.
And the last three, which are to do with our mindfulness,
not just in meditation but in daily life right effort right constant right mindfulness and right concentration okay and and uh and this later on expresses itself in the way we speak the act and what we do this noble eightfold path finds fulfillment in him by development remember he's warned us in an in another discourse that this stuff is gradual
You can't expect quick results.
Very disappointing.
Now, when he develops the Noble Eightfold Path, the four foundations of mindfulness also come to fulfillment by development.
So here we're talking about the Adahad, really, so we've completed the path.
But it shows us the path that actually, you know, which way we have to go.
The four kinds of striving come also to fulfillment in him by development.
the four bases of spiritual power also come to him by development.
The five faculties also come to fulfillment in him by development.
And the seven factors of enlightenment come to fulfillment in him by development.
So here, of course, now he's led us into the eightfold path.
Sorry, he's led us into the 37 requisites for enlightenment.
I don't think it includes the Noble Eightfold Path.
Oh, yes, of course it does.
So you've got the Eight of the Noble Eightfold Path, the four foundations of mindfulness on the body, on feelings, on the mind, and on the Buddha's teachings, which, of course, include the hindrances and the seven factors of enlightenment.
The four kinds of striving.
Remember to abandon what is unwholesome and to stop unwholesomeness coming up.
to increase what is coming up and increase wholesome states that are coming up and stop them from disappearing and keep developing them.
The four kinds of striving, the four bases of power, that was, remember, a real zeal for something, a real energy for it, a real heart commitment to it, and this constant investigation, this constant ability to constant reflection and investigative reflection.
These are the four roads to power or success.
I prefer the translation success.
And remember that these also can be used in ordinary daily life for any task you do, even if you're just cutting the lawn, for instance, a real zeal for it, that sort of commitment to it, a heart's commitment, and being constantly aware of what one's doing and making sure that one is cutting the lawn in the best way possible.
Then, of course, there are the five spiritual faculties.
So here we've got the awareness, effort, concentration.
I've got them in the wrong order here, I think.
Yeah, sorry, faith.
Faith, effort, awareness, concentration, and wisdom.
Now, that panya has both the meaning of a wisdom, what you actually understand through your practice, and
the uh active insight process tanya uh and they become the five powers also so remember that when one has made the first path and fruit these are called powers because they become established in the person especially the faith the confidence so before we've had the experience of libana
or seen deeply into these three characteristics of existence there's always that sense of uh should we say possible doubt but once you've seen it for yourself how can you possibly doubt it hence your confidence is rooted it's it's it's uh powerful it's it's a power and of course the seven factors of enlightenment so remember those pairs uh awareness balances everything but then
You have the effort with the concentration.
Too much effort, you get restless.
Too much concentration, you fall asleep.
And then there's that sense of calmness with the investigation.
If you become excited about investigating something or coming from a wrong position, then, of course, it corrupts it.
And if you investigate without that calmness, then there's usually restlessness there or dullness.
And then finally, yes, equanimity with that process of investigation.
Sorry, I should have said interest, the calmness with the interest.
And then there's the equanimity, not coming from a position, a view, so that you're always looking for what you think you know.
but completely coming from a place of not knowing, not committing yourself to anything, just looking, just clear seeing, and that process of investigation.
Those are the seven factors come to fulfilment in him by development.
Now these two things, concentration and insight, occur in him yoked evenly together.
This is the full liberation.
And he fully understands by direct experience those things that should be fully understood by direct experience.
He abandons by direct knowledge those things that should be abandoned when you know something.
And he develops, because of his direct experience, those things that should be developed.
And he realizes those direct, by his personal experience, those things that should be realized.
Those things belong to the Four Noble Truths, right?
So you understand suffering, you understand the cause of suffering, and you realize how to get rid of it.
Now, what things should be fully understood by direct experience?
The answer is this, the five aggregates, okay?
The five aggregates affected by clinging.
So that's the material form, the feeling aggregate, the perception and conception aggregate, all the formations, all the habits that we have caused by our own will, and finally consciousness.
what should be abandoned by this direct knowledge this direct experience ignorance and craving for becoming right so the ignorance which creates that initial delusion of the self and it's the self that wants to keep recreating itself recommitting itself from one moment to the next and then finally what things should be realized by direct
Acknowledge it should be the way things really are, anicca dukkha anatta, impermanence to cause of suffering, not self, and final deliverance.
Now, when this was, this is what the Blessed One said, and the Bhikkhus were delighted, and more often than not, delighted in the Blessed One's words.
So, this discourse is...
it's like a sort of revision for us so that's it's called the great six-fold base number 149 so i hope that uh that's made you confident that you know the dharma very well and that all you need to do is to keep developing it and before long i without any doubt you will be fully liberated and i do hope sooner rather than later so we can do a bit of practice